[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin schönen guten Abend sven
ist wieder bei mir im Studio später mit
den Sport Highlights mit vielen Rekorden
schönen Abend unsere Themen an diesem
Sonntag
Bauzinsen und Baukosten als Bremser vor
dem Gipfel im Kanzleramt schwindet die
Hoffnung auf mehr Wohnraum
geflüchtete aus Berg Karabach erreichen
Armenien das Land fordert eine
UN-Mission zum Schutz der armenischen
Bevölkerung in der eroberten Region
und Weltrekord beim Berlin-Marathon die
Äthiopien
[Musik]
auch in der deutschen Bauwirtschaft
kriselt es morgen dazu im Kanzleramt
einen Gipfeltreffen mit
Branchenvertretern die Milliarden
schwere Hilfen fordern von bauministerin
galwitz ist zu hören dass sie
Klimaschutzauflagen teilweise aussetzen
will aktuell hängt man etwa beim
geplanten Wohnungsbau dramatisch
hinterher eigentlich hatte die
Bundesregierung das Ziel des pro Jahr
400.000 Wohnungen gebaut werden
tatsächlich waren es vergangenes Jahr
knapp 300.000 und bis Ende Juli dieses
Jahres wurden nur gut 156.000 Wohnungen
genehmigt Ursachen für den Rückgang die
Bauzinsen sind enorm gestiegen ebenso
die Baukosten heißt bauen ist für viele
zu teuer rittermann
es wird noch gebaut aber zu wenig die
Branche klagt über eine toxische Mixtur
zu teuer und zu viele Regeln es herrscht
Frust vor dem Gipfel zwei große
eigentümerverbände haben das Treffen
morgen im Kanzleramt bereits abgesagt
einer von ihnen Haus und Grund die
Regierung hat in der Tat die Zeichen der
Zeit nicht erkannt der Wohnungsmarkt
aber auch der Finanzmarkt haben sich
derart stark bewegt dass der normale
Traum vom Eigenheim nicht mehr erfüllt
werden kann und das führt dazu dass wir
mehr Mieterinnen und Mieter in
Deutschland haben und für die fehlt der
bezahlbarer Wohnraum das bedeutet die
Mieten steigen weiter eine Trendwende
ist nicht in Sicht denn auch die
Bauanträge gingen zuletzt massiv zurück
die bauministerin verfehlt auch dieses
Jahr ihr Ziel 400.000 neue Wohnungen zu
bauen der Druck auf sie mehr zu tun
wächst deshalb werden wir jetzt
konjunkturelle Impulse setzen zusammen
mit den Beiträgen der Länder stehen da
etwa 45 Milliarden Euro bis 2027 zur
Verfügung
das Geld allein ist es nicht kontert die
Branche Vorschriften müssen abgespeckt
Genehmigungen beschleunigt und
Energiestandards lockerer gehandhabt
werden das Bauministerium will offenbar
bei der Energiesanierung auf die Bremse
treten erst öffentliche Gebäude dann
Privathäuser die Union befürchtet
hingegen noch mehr Auflagen nach den
Koalitionsvertrag ist es ja auch so die
energetischen Standards sollen noch
einmal jetzt verschärft werden was das
Bauen noch einmal um 10% verteuern würde
das ist in dieser Situation einfach
nicht angemessen keine guten Vorzeichen
für das Treffen morgen wichtige Akteure
fehlen und es steht diese Forderung im
Raum es brauche einen Doppelpunkt
diesmal für bezahlbares Wohnen
mehr zur Baukrise auch im Interview mit
spd-generalsekretär Kühnert im Anschluss
bei den Kollegen von Berlin direkt ja
für SPD-Chef klingenball gibt es kein
Patentrezept gegen irreguläre Migration
er weigere sich so zu tun als gäbe es
die eine zaubermaßnahme sagte er der
Bild am Sonntag solche Maßnahmen liefert
nur populistische Schlagzeilen
stattdessen fordert er einen Bündel von
Aktionen um die Zuwanderung zu begrenzen
bei einer Stichwahl im thüringischen
Nordhausen ging es heute darum ob die
AFD erstmals eine Oberbürgermeisterwahl
gewinnt
afd-kandidat Jörg Prophet gab seine
Stimme schon am Morgen ab der
unternehmertrat gegen den
parteilosenamtsinhaber Kai Buchmann an
insgesamt waren knapp 33.000 Menschen
aufgerufen ihre Stimme abzugeben
Melanie Haag ist für uns in Nordhausen
Melanie wonach sieht es aus
ja also man muss sagen seit 18 Uhr läuft
hier im Grunde ein Wahlkrimi die beiden
liefern sich einen Kopf an Kopf Rennen
noch fehlen vier Stimmbezirke der
afd-kandidat liegt derzeit bei
46,2% und der amtierende
Oberbürgermeister der parteilose liegt
derzeit bei 53,8% das zeigt im Grunde
wie gespalten Nordhausen auch ist eine
Stadt dirigiert wurde von einem
parteilosen Oberbürgermeister der auch
sich einem Disziplinarverfahren
ausgesetzt sieht viele queren politische
queren in den letzten Jahren die auch
Teil des Frust der Bürger sind die wir
hier in Thüringen und speziell in
Nordhausen erleben und dann die Hoffnung
in den afd-kandidaten der sehr sich sehr
Heimat verbunden gibt Unternehmer in der
Region ist gleichzeitig aber vom
Thüringer Verfassungsschutz zitiert wird
und dort belegt man ihm ein erwiesen
revisionistisches Geschäft
Geschichtsbild was so viel bedeutet dass
er die historische Schuld der Deutschen
relativiert und das in Nordhausen in
einer Stadt in der das ehemalige
Konzentrationslager Mittelbau Dora liegt
also um zusammenzufassen wir stehen kurz
vor dem Ergebnis Koffern kopfrennen und
im Moment sieht es nicht danach aus dass
die AFD den künftigen Oberbürgermeister
stellt Dankeschön nach Nordhausen
Melanie Haag jetzt zur Konfliktregion
Berg carabach der armenische
Außenminister fordert eine UN-Mission
ziel sei es die Sicherheit der
Bevölkerung dort zu gewährleisten seit
Tagen gehen armenische Demonstranten
gegen ihre Regierung auf die Straße sie
werfen ihr vor Berg Karabach
leichtfertig aufgegeben zu haben
inzwischen sind erste Flüchtlinge aus
Bergkarabach in Armenien angekommen Nina
niedergal berichtet aus der Hauptstadt
es sind Tränen der Erleichterung
tagelang waren sie eingeschlossenen Berg
Karabach jetzt endlich haben sie es nach
Armenien geschafft einige hundert
durften heute die Grenze passieren aber
die Unsicherheit ist groß auch bei denen
die sich schon an den russischen
Militärstützpunkt gerettet haben wer
kann uns Garantien geben wir haben einen
Liter Benzin gefunden sind geflohen und
hierher gekommen wenn wir jetzt gehen
werden dann die jungen Leute die bleiben
umgebracht ihre Toten müssen sie
zurücklassen diese Gräber erst am Morgen
ausgehoben etwa 200 Menschen sollen bei
dem aserbaidschanischen Angriff am
Dienstag getötet worden sein
Susanna petrossians Mutter und
Geschwister gehören zu denen die
festsitzen morgen sollen sie ausreisen
dürfen falls die aserbaidschanische
Armee sie lässt
sie Dörfer waren von Aserbaidschanern
umstellt vielleicht werden sie Ihnen
morgen einen Korridor geben um ihr Land
für immer zu verlassen
in Eriwan sind viele wütend über die
Ereignisse tausende protestieren am
Abend in der armenischen Hauptstadt
viele Armenia und armenierinnen sind
unzufrieden sie sagen man hätte länger
um bergkara Bach kämpfen müssen und die
Region nicht so schnell aufgeben sie
sagen außerdem es können nicht sein dass
die Menschen nur eine Option haben und
die lautet ihre Heimat zu verlassen
sondern es müssen auch die Möglichkeit
geben menschenwürdig weiter in
bergkamera Bach leben zu können doch
viele werden wohl fliehen Armenien
bereitet sich auf 40.000 Flüchtlinge vor
im Norden des Kosovos seine Polizei
Strafe beschossen worden ein Polizist
wurde dabei getötet mehrere weitere
verletzt die Beamten wollten eine
Straßenblockade nahe der Grenze zu
Serbien auflösen als sie mit schweren
Waffen angegriffen wurden der Kosovo
beschuldigt Serbien hinter dem Angriff
zu stecken in den letzten Monaten hatte
es in der Region immer wieder gewaltsame
Auseinandersetzung gegeben
der US-Bundesstaat Utah hat sozusagen
frachtpost aus dem All bekommen in der
Wüste dort landete nach einem gut
100.000 Kilometer langen Fall eine
Raumkapsel an Bord Proben vom Asteroiden
Benno vor drei Jahren hatte eine
us-sonde dort etwa 250 Gramm Geröll
eingesammelt und jetzt kontrolliert
abgeworfen es ist die erste NASA Mission
dieser Art Wissenschaftler hoffen jetzt
auf Erkenntnisse über Benno der Asteroid
könnte der Erde in 150 Jahren recht nah
kommen
und jetzt sind wir beim Sport wenn und
es geht los mit mehreren Rekorden für
Rekorde ist der Berlin-Marathon immer
ein gutes Pflaster tigist aceta lief
heute in Weltrekordzeit über die
Ziellinie die Äthiopien verbesserte die
alte Marke um mehr als 2 Minuten bei
fast perfekten Bedingungen
auch der Protest der klimaaktivisten
kurz vor dem Start konnte tigist ass Eva
nicht aufhalten in einer fabelhaften
Zeit von 2 Stunden 11 Minuten und 53
Sekunden läuft die 29-Jährige Äthiopien
Weltrekord im Marathon eine Verbesserung
von mehr als 2 Minuten der vier Jahre
alten westmarke von Brigitte und Chicago
zum fünften Mal in Berlin gewinnt Elliot
kipschorke bei den Männern in zwei
Stunden zwei Minuten 42 Sekunden auch
das eine Bestmarke ideale Bedingungen
ermöglichen auch eine neue deutsche
Bestzeit am anal Petros und der Boot in
zwei Stunden vier Minuten und 58
Sekunden den von ihm aufgestellten
Rekord umfasst eineinhalb Minuten und
wird Neunter
und im ersten Sonntagsspiel in der
Fußball-Bundesliga schlug Leverkusen
Aufsteiger Heidenheim mit vier zu eins
zwei Tore erzielte Viktor Bonny face Max
Verstappen hat den Großen Preis von
Japan gewonnen mit seinem 13 Saisonsieg
ist er auf dem Weg zu seinem dritten
WM-Titel nacheinander verstappens Erfolg
machte Red Bull vorzeitig zum
Konstrukteurs Weltmeister
Teamchef Christian Horner und Max
Verstappen feiern den WM-Titel
angemessen
und ich bin stolz auf jeden egal ob hier
oder in der Fabrik denn es ist eine
Teamleistung die wir gezeigt haben nur
zu Beginn des Rennens muss ich max
Verstappen den Angriffen der
Konkurrenten er wären die mir klaren von
piastri links und Noris rechts bleiben
jedoch von Paris kommen heute keine
WM-Punkte für Red Bull damit gefährdet
der künftig seinen Platz im
Weltmeisterteam die Werks Mercedes mit
Hamilton und Russel nur Rang 5 und 7 mit
Platz zwei und drei von London
Jahren Mercedes ihnen klar die Show
gestohlen
und das war es vom sportmetri ich danke
dir Sven wir schauen ganz fix aufs
Wetter morgen scheint nach Auflösung
einiger Nebelfelder die Sonne die
Temperatur die steigt auf 18 bis 24 Grad
wir empfehlen das heute journal mit
Dunja Hayali um 21 Uhr morgen sehen wir
uns wenn Sie mögen wieder jetzt gehen
wir rüber in die Hauptstadt zu Berlin
direkt und Theo
vielen Dank vitri und herzlich
Willkommen zu Berlin direkt morgen ist
baugipfel im Kanzleramt und es dürfte
ein Krisengipfel werden es fehlen
hunderttausende Wohnung die Mieten
schnell in die Höhe die Bauwirtschaft
waren vor dem Zusammenbruch und wir
schauen auf Renten Pensionen und auf
Frau Bock